the justice league is vaporized in a
single blast and mr fantastic ends up a
pile of blue spaghetti it's been a rough
year for superheroes here's who's dead
like his sons thor and loki odin appears
in marvel comics and movies dc comics
various works of fantasy and of course
north mythology mcu viewers associate
the all father with anthony hopkins
portrayal in the first three thor movies
as is the case with asgard itself
marvel's odin goes through cycles of
destruction and rebirth he
dematerializes into particles of bright
light at the beginning of thor ragnarok
and similarly wills himself out of
existence at the conclusion of 2022's
thor number 22 by writer donnie cates
and artist nick klein
i'm on a different path now
this you must face alone in this
penultimate installment of kate's god of
hammers arc odin reveals that his
continued existence is preventing thor
the current king of asgard from wielding
the full cosmic might usually at the
disposal of his royal station
recognizing that thor needs an extra
boost to defeat the renegade god of
hammers a blend of mjolnir's energy and
the nefarious mangog odin releases the
last of his power to his son erasing
himself in the process
in 2016 suicide squad only two members
of task force x bite the big one in
contrast 2021's the suicide squad
includes a wholesale massacre of dc
sealist baddies fortunately this
slaughter does not include peacemaker
allowing him to return for his hbo max
series perhaps in the interest of
consistency with the film peacemaker
ends season 1 with fewer characters than
it starts most of these characters are
ordinary humans or members of the
hostile alien race colloquially known as
butterflies the butterfly eek no bloke
who inhabits the body of ex-mercenary
clemson mirn is sort of both and in many
respects his ultimately self-sacrificing
quest to prevent his fellow butterflies
from annihilating the human race
qualifies as super heroic after the
butterflies take over the police force
of evergreen washington mirn throws
himself under the metaphorical bus to
allow harcourt and adebayo to evade
execution and carry on with their
mission in a tragic twist the butterfly
eek stack geek eek sometimes referred to
as goth and inhabiting the body of the
detective sophie's song happens to be
the individual who repeatedly pulls the
trigger on mern
we haven't seen a ton of super pets
since 1985's crisis on infinite earths
reset the dc universe's timeline and
removed them from officially recognized
existence so it's nice to see crypto the
super dog and comet the super horse make
something of a comeback in 2021's
supergirl woman of tomorrow the eight
issue epic sends cara zorel on a galaxy
spanning journey she's determined to
track down krem an interstellar pirate
who needlessly slew her friend's father
then poisoned crypto while making his
escape by the time the final issue
arrives supergirl has successfully
detained krem however krem manages to
send for a cavalry of space pirates to
help reverse his fortune after a
significant struggle supergirl manages
to dispatch these baddies but comet
loses his life in the process it's a
little ambiguous whether supergirl woman
of tomorrow is a canonical tale so this
comet's precise nature is difficult to
pin down but supergirl does mention that
she knew he was a man cursed to live as
a horse a fact he didn't love talking
about this death might not stick but
it's still enormously moving
netflix threw its hat into the superhero
satire ring with 2022's the guardians of
justice reminiscent of the boys
invincible and hbo's watchmen the
guardians of justice doesn't treat the
cape and cowell set as spotless heroes
marvelous man this universe is superman
equivalent seemingly dies live on
television but some of his colleagues
suspect foul play
so i found my escape no don't do this
much like rorschach's search for the
comedian's killer kicks off watchmen the
guardians of justice joins nighthawk as
he explores the mystery of marvelous
man's death but who is marvelous man he
arrived on earth after his home planet
was destroyed by a brainiac like villain
like any wannabe superman worth assault
marvelous man can fly has heat vision
boasts seemingly impossible strength and
is virtually invulnerable to all
potential harm except for this world's
kryptonite equivalent the copyright safe
version of a kryptonite bullet that
kills him is ostensibly stolen from a
stand-in for lex luthor sound bizarre it
is but that's the guardians of justice
in a copyright safe kryptonite laced
nutshell in 2022's the human target
private investigator christopher chance
aka the human target ingests a slow
acting poison intended for lex luthor he
has 12 days to figure out who's to blame
for his rapidly approaching death and
the hard-boiled gumshoe suspects the
involvement of at least one member of
justice league international the ensuing
tale blends elements of noir detective
traditions and the irreverent side of dc
publishing that emerged in the late
1980s and early 1990s whether or not tom
king and greg smallwood's mini-series
takes place in the mainstream dc
timeline is unclear therefore guy
gardner may appear in another more
canonical story before the end of the
year or even re-emerge somehow in the
human target nevertheless the fact
remains that the green lantern corps's
biggest jerk is killed in a fight with
ice his ex and chris chance in the human
target number six originally one of
christopher's suspects sub-zero's super
heroine ice eventually becomes his
romantic interest much to guys jealous
fury the third most famous green lantern
attacks the new couple after a night of
passion only to find himself frozen
solid and shattered to pieces in that
order let that be a lesson to awful exes
everywhere nothing good ever comes from
stalking and harassment even if you have
a power ring from space
plenty of folks who'd like to get into
superhero comics find themselves stymied
by dc and marvel's convoluted continuity
jarring reboots and reliance upon
obscure characters with omnipotent
powers appearing from out of nowhere
they've got a new hurdle to clear
courtesy of justice league number 75 by
joshua williamson and rafa sandoval in
this issue a previously benevolent
dimensional traveler named pariah
effortlessly dematerializes a sizable
fraction of dc's best known usually
unstoppable champions of virtue
specifically pariah kills the justice
league superman batman wonder woman
green lantern zatanna aquaman hot girl
and the martian manhunter all evaporate
into nothing he also bumps off
multi-dimensional justice leaguers
including president superman of earth 23
dr multiverse of earth 8 captain carrot
of earth 23 and a handful of others
promotional materials tell us this
ghastly traumatizing massacre of
globally beloved characters leads into
dc's summer of 2022 event dark crisis
all of this is plenty shocking by itself
but here's the kicker current action
comic scribe philip kennedy johnson has
already made it known via an interview
with cbr that superman's death will in
no way interrupt kal-el's noble struggle
against intergalactic tyranny and
depression in his concurrent war world
saga likewise ceasing to exist doesn't
seem to be stopping batman from hunting
razal ghoul's assassin in the shadow war
multi-series crossover dc's most
prominent heroes have died in justice
league somehow they all continue to
prosper in their solo adventures what
gives we suppose we'll have to keep
reading
fans of the fantastic four have waited
years for marvel's first family to take
their rightful place at the center of
the mcu and they probably won't have to
stay patient for much longer even though
it's currently in need of a new director
marvel's fantastic four should come to
fruition within the not so distant
future hopefully the version of reed
richards from the mainstream mcu
timeline fares a little better than the
reed who leads the illuminati from
earth838 because that guy dies a swift
and humiliating death in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness the scarlet
witch chases steven strange and america
chavez to earth 838 hoping to use
america's dimension-hopping powers to
reunite with her sons earth-838's
illuminati a secretive group of elite
superheroes do not initially take the
threat of the scarlet witch seriously if
they can beat thanos how much of a
problem could wanda maximoff possibly be
right as it happens the scarlet witch
controls reality itself so she turns
reed into string cheese and then makes
his brains explode
the inhumans tv show is the biggest
abject failure in mcu history and there
isn't a close second the x-men's movie
rights returning to marvel pretty much
destroys any remaining chance of the
inhumans occupying the mcu's lane for
genetically gifted outcasts and black
bolt probably died the most gruesome and
unsettling demise of any illuminati
member in multiverse of madness which is
saying something after reed richards of
earth 838 informs wanda that blackbolt
can annihilate her with a whisper wanda
simply smirks and uses her magic
what mouth
the king of the inhumans then notices
that his mouth has vanished he panics
and the resulting yelp causes his skull
to pop like a blister we don't think the
mainstream mcu timeline's black bolt
also played by anson mount would ever be
dumb enough to use his unfathomably
destructive vocal cords while his mouth
was sewn shut he might be a commercial
failure but the black bolt of the abc
television network is probably way
harder to kill than this guy
since arriving on the scene in 2011's
captain america the first avenger peggy
carter has journeyed from movies to
network television to streaming
animation while anyone who watched abc's
agent carter can attest to the combat
prowess of the version of peggy who
resides in the regular mcu timeline the
peggy variant from what if captain
carter were the first avenger would
probably be more useful in a fight
against doctor doom the disney plus
series what if tells us the tale of
captain carter a time displaced world
war ii era hero who's injected with the
super soldier serum when the original
test subject steve rogers is made
temporarily unavailable however we can
safely presume the events of what if are
not directly connected to conditions on
earth 838 captain carter is slated for
significant amounts of screen time in
what if season 2 and the earth 83
variant of peggy is all out of time
screen related or otherwise relative to
the other illuminati members captain
carter puts up a decent fight against
the scarlet witch she even manages to
land a few strikes before wanda takes
telepathic control of captain carter's
signature shield and uses it to separate
peggy's lower half from the rest of her
torso
in the primary mcu timeline maria rambo
is carol danvers friend and the mother
of monica rambo she sadly passes away
during the years between infinity war
and endgame but not before making a big
impact in the world of the mcu by
founding sword in earth 838 maria became
captain marvel instead of carol danvers
and she went on to join reed richards
illuminati sharing the attitude of the
rest of her pompous secret society maria
tells strange they can handle your
little witch if wanda maximoff shows up
looking for america chavez as it turns
out earth 838's captain marvel can't
handle the little witch who squashes
captain marvel by dropping a statue on
her somewhat curiously earth 838 maria
wears a teal-colored costume similar to
the uniform carol danvers fights in
during her time as the amnesiac cree
warrior verse in 2019's captain marvel
in theory this could indicate that some
sort of diplomatic relationship exists
between the cree and the governments of
earth 838 but who knows if we'll ever
hear more about this timeline's history
patrick stewart played professor charles
xavier for the first time back in the
year 2000's x-men and once said he'd
step away from the role after the high
note of 2017's logan apparently kevin
feige used mind control abilities of his
own to convince stewart to play xavier
for the eighth time in multiverse of
madness although in fairness since the
earth-838 variant of the benevolent
mutant telepath technically isn't the
same person we see leading the x-men in
any 20th century studios x-men movies
stewart could somewhat credibly argue
that he never went back on his word like
the rest of the illuminati earth838
professor x finds himself utterly
overwhelmed by the scarlet witch who
creeps up behind him while he's inside
wanda's mind and snaps his neck like a
celery stick we wish we could have seen
more of professor x in the multiverse of
madness especially after stewart's
authoritative declaration of we should
tell him the truth was so heavily
featured in trailers
unpredictable explosions of grotesque
violence are a huge part of the appeal
of amazon prime's the boys based on the
remains that homelander shows to
starlight in glorious 5-year plan it's
hard to tell exactly what the leader of
the 7 did to supersonic it looks like
homelander punched his face into his
skull and cut his leg off with his heat
vision but we can only speculate on the
precise nature of super sonic's multiple
fatal injuries years before winning the
american hero reality show competition
and joining the seven super sonic had
been starlight's first boyfriend and
nothing we see on the boys indicates
that he was anything short of a perfect
gentleman in fact his friendship with
starlight and his principled inclination
towards doing the right thing is exactly
what ultimately lands him in homelanders
crosshairs stop it you know how that
ends
little is known of the winged soup known
as swado other than he was a member of
payback and a close associate of soldier
boy during the 1980s while his demise
was needless and tragic it provides a
teachable moment for the rest of us it's
important to remember certain abilities
are less useful than others in specific
situations in this instance while the
power of hovering flight is handy for
rescuing cats from trees it's utterly
worthless against enemies wielding
anti-air artillery we know payback's
1984 mission in nicaragua is primarily
notable for the disappearance of soldier
boy and subsequent government cover-up
however the fiasco also marks the final
moments of suado
the green lantern of sector 2813 made
his first comic book appearance in the
early 1960s and has remained a
consistent supporting cast member in
comics animated series and video games
tomorrow is a fairly significant
relative to the hundreds of other dc
characters who've been created over the
years and talking about him as if he
might as well be a red shirt from star
trek the original series is a little
preposterous nevertheless it happens to
be the case that the young justice
version of toma rey is killed battling
lorzad on new genesis in the season 4
episode odyssey of death while he's
introduced a few episodes earlier he
doesn't get a ton of time in the
spotlight before the curtains fall that
said he makes the most of the few
moments he does have on screen tomorrow
explains that his failure to prevent the
destruction of krypton has haunted him
for decades see he knew and admired
superman's biological father jor-el
while tomorrow himself doesn't survive
lorzad's assault he does manage to save
new genesis from sharing krypton's fate
and wraps up his tenure in the universe
with a little bit of redemption
one of the ex-payback members who
betrays soldier boy crimson countess
might be one of the most bearable
affiliates of the original vaught super
team naturally there's some degree of
narcissism and a savior complex
motivating her advocacy for endangered
chimpanzees but at least she channels
her personality shortcomings in a
positive direction though the fact that
these days she calls a small trailer her
home perhaps her one true weakness is
sound financial investing speaking of
her trailer that's where she's blasted
off the face of existence by an
exploding soldier boy a fate shared by
numerous characters in the third season
of amazon's pitch black superhero satire
maybe it's a little cold to turn your
boyfriend over to hostile military
scientists but at the end of the day
wasn't helping put soldier boy out of
commission the right thing to do
we don't spend a ton of time with blue
hawk on the boys he's only in a few
episodes and mostly exists to serve as a
ruthless commentary on how american
police have handled the deaths of george
floyd and numerous others
i go with the crimes and the crime just
happens to be
in black neighborhoods
blue hawks swears he's not racist but he
also insists that hip-hop doesn't count
as real music he went all the way down
the birtherism rabbit hole during the
obama administration and frequently
bemoans the perceived unfairness of his
inability to say racial slurs in public
without social consequences a train has
made some unfortunate choices over the
years but breaking the sound barrier
while dragging bluehawk across the
pavement probably isn't on his list of
regrets
the tnt twins were former members of
payback who when they held hands could
shoot lightning like bursts and baddies
but that's definitely not what we
remember them for more memorably the tnt
twins are the hosts of herogasm in the
boys season 3. as we see from a
flashback to the 1980s they were
essentially useless in serious combat
situations back in their heyday the tnt
twins shot a little laser that made a
big noise and could knock people over
meaning virtually any ranged weapon
would have been more effective than
their so-called superpowers as a result
they functioned a little more like
television personalities than what we
typically think of as superheroes by the
time soldier boy catches up to them at
hirogasm their powers no longer work at
all due to years of neglect by the end
of their lives tommy and tessa are more
like aging circus performers than
one-time crime fighters so even if you
don't approve of their lifestyle choices
one has to wonder if they really deserve
to be victims of soldier boy's homicidal
rampage
in the latest thor movie jane foster is
dying of cancer while she devotes her
dwindling existence to defending
innocent people from all manner of
cosmic threats i just want to say that
was very very impressive what she did
back there however thor love and thunder
is only partly jane's movie for pretty
understandable reasons chris hemsworth
is still very much the star of the show
in the continuity of the mcu jane spent
several years away from the spotlight
but the latest film in the franchise
sees her triumphant return this time as
more than a basic love interest sometime
after her experiences in 2011's thor and
2013's thor the dark world jane foster
breaks up with intergalactically
acknowledged hunk thor following a
diagnosis of late stage cancer jane
finds herself drawn to the asgardian
hammer mjolnir which declares her worthy
and transforms her into the mighty thor
tragically the magic hammer is unable to
cure her illness in fact using the
weapon is actually hurting her but she
chooses to pick up mjolnir and save her
as guardian boyfriend right as he's
about to meet his fate as a result of
her selfless decision she dies shortly
after the final confrontation with gore
the godbutcher and is welcomed into
valhalla
while we lost numerous heroes a few
villains also didn't survive 2022
with so many super villains hatching so
many devious plots at all times you'd
think there'd be no original scheme for
world domination left untried orm the
ocean master from young justice is
basically loki with far less charisma
but let's give him credit he attempts
what truly seems to be an original evil
plan correctly guessing he could charm
the people of atlantis by embodying an
imagined glorious past ocean master
transplants his consciousness into a
clone of arion the original leader of
the undersea kingdom ocean master wins
major battles and makes plenty of
inspiring speeches to cover his bases he
also clones himself and loads that clone
up with memories so only an expert mind
reader could sniff out his ruse this is
your chance to redeem yourself before
the light and achieve everything i have
ever dreamt of
as it happens the young justice crew
includes prominent telepath mcgann moraz
who easily figures out what's up but by
the time mcgann warns the atlanteans of
ocean masters presence in arion's body
at the end of season 4's leviathan wakes
it's too late arion is declared the new
king of atlantis luckily thanks to an
ancient prophecy involving the lords of
order and vandal savage arion
spectacularly explodes the instant he
puts the crown on his head
long-time arch-nemesis bruce wayne and
scary grandpa to damien wayne ross
al-ghul is assassinated at the onset of
dc shadow war event causing plenty of
readers to roll their eyes not only does
roz the centuries-old one-time leader of
the league of assassins benefit from the
same squishy relationship with mortality
that keeps the rest of dc and marvel's
denizens uniquely prone to resurrections
immortality is kind of his whole deal in
the past when injuries or illness had
raz skirting the edges of the great
beyond he'd retreat to the lazarus pit a
literal fountain of youth and regenerate
his body into that of a younger
healthier megalomaniacal eco-terrorist
basically razal ghul dying and not
coming back is kind of like if the joker
stopped doing murders and laughing at
ironically morbid circumstances it just
feels wrong even if it's clearly a
positive development for the citizens of
gotham city but implausible as it seems
after shadow war a multi-title crossover
penned by joshua williamson rosal ghoul
remains as apparently deceased as he
does at the beginning damien is still
pretty messed up about the death of
alfred pennyworth and now he's lost his
literal grandfather shortly after his
surrogate grandfather
when the mercenary forces of talia
al-ghul and death stroke throw down in
shadow war a lot of them die including
respawn the promising young killing
machine debuts in the league of lazarus
deathmatch tournament seen in the pages
of 2021's robin he initially appears to
have lifted his costume style and
gimmick from deathstroke but respawn is
much more than a slade wilson fanboy
razal ghul being an utterly insane
scientific genius mixed genetic material
from his daughter talia and deathstroke
to create the mercenary damian wayne is
initially psyched to find out he has a
half-brother but his excitement is
short-lived shortly after the two meet
respawn hurls himself in front of a hail
of bullets and various other projectile
weapons intended for slade and as a
result he is ripped to shreds
over the years young justice has done a
spectacular job establishing its unique
vision of the teen titans but its takes
on the dc universe's big bad guys tend
to feel a little traditional the light
is a pretty faithful version of the
legion of doom villains linked with
markovia and apocalypse routinely appear
in other dc animated projects and the
general zod of young justice phantoms to
his credit is not a major departure from
terence stamps zod of yore
come to me son of jerrell
kneel before zone
but that brings us to lorzad elder zod's
savvy and cold-blooded son a profoundly
dangerous foil for superboy and the
legion of superheroes lorzad feels like
a deranged sociopath who is specific to
young justice however season 4 ends with
lorzad teleporting into a bomb blast on
mars that vaporizes him immediately but
that doesn't mean we'll never see him
again he is a time traveler after all
even if lorzad is permanently toast the
final moments of phantoms lead us to
believe a hypothetical next season will
definitely not share the uninteresting
villain problems of previous seasons
[Music]